dude not that I'm on reddit first up
what's been going on on the know first
of the that pictures I sent the other
day of the winners of the Invitational
well when we pull that up again yes so
this team is the first time this is the
first team to win this tournament twice
this is like that big dota tournament
okay
oh yeah that like flyer you sent yeah or
to deal with that they won fifteen
million dollars what yeah that's what it
says on the bubble five split five ways
holy [ __ ]
yeah so three million each roughly
that's crazy 15 mil bro [ __ ] yeah that's
why they're making all these goofy ass
faces yeah is that here let's see this
[ __ ] Harry Potter
I know Quidditch team no it looks like I
was gonna say it looks like a Madame
Tussaud magician Act five five man
magician act it Madame Tussaud yeah
seriously
so they won two years in a row not in a
row but I think they won so these
[ __ ] are rich yeah yeah that's
why they're good as good as faces yeah
yeah talk [ __ ] about gaming one more
time talk [ __ ] about dota I can't hear
you my Ferraris too loud yeah exactly
yeah yeah it's so funny [ __ ] that's
crazy man mm-hmm that tournament is
crazy he said what is it was it like in
a stadium yeah it's huge okay I mean
dude that like the I've said that I'm
sorry when was the last episode but like
the the booths they billed for the teams
it's like they're all glass soundproofed
like it like fits like staff you know
it's like you got your five players and
their [ __ ] whoever captain like
standing behind them like calling strat
and just whatever calling strat oh yeah
mm-hmm
actually I don't know if that they have
a I think cuz in counter-strike you can
have like a strike hauler I believe you
have a sixth man like on the mic who can
who can speak really I think so yeah and
he just tell he's
like a coach bro yeah dude
counter-strike strat is crazy
I was like that you abbreviate that
every time strat strategy
yeah no it's trap I've never heard
anyone shorten that before gaming bro
it's calling strap weave calling strat
yeah yeah who guys who got this draw my
abbreviation but this is the first you
can't say that every round what is the
strategy brother you can't know what's
the strat it was that kind of just point
it was that was it's right you can just
say like that yeah strat some work strap
question more stretch stretch we were
joking yesterday that like cuz we were
drinking in all the scenes uh-huh
and it was all like fake like just water
or like food coloring in water
yeah we're just joking about if it was
real there's nobody see [ __ ] up for
the stand by the end we're just like the
eyes it like just just saying sounds I
fired one of my lines was Johnny stop or
joking yeah Chet Chester it's so [ __ ]
up or just do it all bad
yeah like the emotion doesn't match yeah
I think real serious you gonna be like
Johnny Johnny star yeah just walk in do
every line really bad yeah like the
troll movie or whatever yeah yeah bro
strap strap I turn the whole reason I
played is gonna tune into the starladder
tournament which i've never heard of
their tour a thousand people watching
Jesus yeah walk and then and then old
World of Warcraft is back so they call
it Wow classic everyone's playing that
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] is that I've
seen some [ __ ] about that it's like
we're back in 2005 this is so lame dude
it is so [ __ ] lame doctor disrespect
was clowning he's like I'm not playing
that whoa Wow
classic bull he's like hitting
little dragons gaining XP hidden cute
little animals and stuff now we're here
to play real games this Alton commented
like to be honest he kind of made wild
classic sound kind of cool do you think
it was like it wasn't like propaganda
back in the days where WoW was huge that
it was just like destroying people's
lives remember like no that was shitty
all of the [ __ ] in the news about wow
cuz I never played it but like
everything I ever heard about that game
was that it sucks you in and it [ __ ]
up your life I mean me and any and
people like would go to rehab for a
while like it was like something is like
an addiction no that's how I understood
it I mean I think that was partially Fox
News just trying to say video games or
you know the reason for dark [ __ ] but
also like wow definitely [ __ ] people's
life yeah like it was also people that I
that I met who played it that were like
I think that were like thank God I got
out now like thank [ __ ] god I got out
cuz dude it was like it was the first of
its kind like a true MMORPG like you
only heard of that I felt like like that
sort of there were other games that were
arguably better that did the MMO concept
well but I think Wow was just the most
like mainstream and it's cut it was like
the fortnight of that time mm-hmm
it was just like a game yeah but people
did like for and I didn't ruin people's
a lot no but that's because like there's
ten years of gaming now like online and
and and sort of like in that like to
that degree yeah
wow I felt like was the first game where
everyone [ __ ] plated everyone and it
was like at any point in time he could
be like you want to go raid right now
yeah dude yeah let's go do it
[ __ ] everything let's go raid I'm 25 who
gives a [ __ ] the Internet's way cooler
than real life yeah job who gives a [ __ ]
yeah I'll just live at home I want to
play this [ __ ] yeah all day yeah and you
know people got out of it and now they
realize I got [ __ ] that was so [ __ ] up
but yeah that would that was true I knew
so many people that fought their life oh
because Wow mmm my [ __ ] buddies they
were they
so I had just quit playing
counter-strike and my buddies kept
playing and there's this league that
they played in and they went on to be
like a top team like like one of the you
know arguably one of the best teams at
that time you know and they started
playing Wow and like it just destroyed
them like the team just fell apart they
didn't want to play counter-strike
anymore they just like pissed that all
away that's what I mean it's not [ __ ]
weird it's crazy yeah it's crazy
well I just think some the game is
cursed cursed yeah think about it man
think about it just serious I you know
be honest no I don't think it's a good
thing it's just I have knives no
knowledge yet anything I think all that
game is terrible cursed yeah I think
it's cursed it does bad things to you
it's the only game where I've like you
know other games like there's there's a
positive connotation whenever people
talk about them it's like yeah call duty
yeah I was addicted to it but like it
was like some of the most fun I've ever
had in my entire life
I think that's why you've never had now
you've never heard that way wow people
are just like yeah I've just I just
it's like repetition I just loved yeah
just [ __ ] rating and yeah you know
this is like routine yeah it's like this
thing you get sucked into or that's what
you have to do it and it's just like no
one ever was like oh my god
I remember so fondly my wow days it's
always like oh yeah I was I was into
that game for a while yeah thank God I
[ __ ] quit yeah no yeah that's true
everyone that plays plays wow is like
and then when Wow classic came out you
hear the way everyone's talking about
like ooh time to [ __ ] my life up again
yeah yeah that's what I mean it's it's
basically the heroine of games yeah
that's one thing is that good [ __ ] yeah
and then the new [ __ ] doesn't hit the
same black tar yeah definitely yeah of
video games where it's like Call of
Duty's more like cocaine yeah I could
never get into wow I played it for like
a month and I was like this is so
[ __ ] boring and people were like
trying to tell me how to yeah you're
just gonna go to this part of the map
and you're just gonna like
little animals and you're gonna farm and
then you're gonna get XP and then I'm
like for what
I mean they're like you get a dragon you
get cool armor and you get to like I'm
like I gotta play six months just to
play with other people cuz I'm too low
level I'll play as goofy as [ __ ] [ __ ]
I gotta wait six months to have fun yes
plane up like that yeah
went right back to quake nice yeah yeah
I don't know everyone's playing it right
now though that's crazy wait and they're
streaming it too
oh yeah tap man everybody really yeah so
for night he's like dead well the that
so they they reverted that thing they
did the other day okay yeah welcome to
the gaming hour yeah welcome to the
gaming hour I'm a Gaiman I'm a gay man
I'm a gaming calm I'm a gaming yeah they
um what are you doing I'm a gaming I'm a
gaming I'm a game in I'm into gaming see
you sir I love gaming what what I love
gaming okay I just thought you were
saying something
yeah I'm in today's games I'm in the
gang I'm voguing gaming I'm a [ __ ]
gaming yeah Lauren I'd almost died like
overnight they made that change the
turbo building and literally everyone
was I am NOT playing this and then it
seems like they're trying to kill it no
I think they got I think they finally
like got shook that's no fastest they've
ever changed something I feel like that
was like within 24 hours like I'll [ __ ]
and they they put it back like it it
makes me wonder this is [ __ ] just
boring as [ __ ] but it makes me wonder
like if if they just if there if they
changed it as a reactionary thing or if
they were really trying to improve the
game like if it would have just [ __ ]
left it like it was what it'd still be
semi popular oh yeah were they changing
it because they saw like a downward
graph and they're trying to create
like drama or whatever or just trying to
create like some some mechanic that made
it grow again or they were they changing
it because it was like a pre-emptive
thing it's like well we don't want to
see this growth decline so we're just
gonna change it for the sake of like God
changes him that's not broken you know I
mean yeah the I mean it seems like they
just [ __ ] it up yeah they kind of I
don't know I mean the I I'm into the
theory that they're trying to kill the
game because they got a new game they
want to put out yeah but that's weird
like if you have something that's just
pumping money mm-hmm like just it's a
cash machine why the [ __ ] would you
purposely kill that for another game
that you don't even know is gonna work
it's a good question I mean I don't know
I that's the part of the gaming industry
I don't understand but it seems to be
that like maybe that's the cycle for for
games like fortnight with like DLC and
all that [ __ ] like it's like it had the
initial hype it leveled out now it's
like in just a steady like you know just
drop off or they see the drop off coming
mm-hm so maybe in their mind like I
don't I don't think it's like some TMZ
[ __ ] where they think like oh we're
gonna make this change and piss everyone
off and like undo it I don't I don't
think it's that I legitimately think
that it's either a they are slowly
making changes with the idea that well
yeah we want to sort of you know we
understand the pro players are a little
frustrated we want to wean them off the
game it's given us ideas about a new
game we want to put out and so we kind
of want to kill the competitive nature
of fortnight in order to put out this
new game and and you know whatever and I
think there's maybe a lot of like
thinking that goes into that because you
know obviously pro gamers and streamers
and stuff I think they kind of dictate
the pace of like popularity and like
what kids play and [ __ ] you know like
little kids but I want them I want to
play the tap man's playing or whatever
yeah and so yeah we saw a kid in Regina
that had a ninja's hair that was crazy
that was the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it was like a probably like a 12 year
old kid had it half of his head dyed
purple and the other half blue yeah just
because that's exactly how ninja had it
at that point it's crazy
I wanted so bad to comment on his
Instagram post
where he was like new hair ninja yeah
cuz it's all purple now right I just
wanted to comment shits clean bro yeah
yeah you should you all day I don't know
I should have done it just clean it do
it just fine shit's clean just fine my
guy
[Music]